دكتور.  فرانسيس ريتو هي
أخصائية أمراض معدية في الخطوط
الأمامية للحرب على فيروس كورونا منذ أول
وفاة مؤكدة لـ kovat 19 في الولايات المتحدة.
ريتو وصحة دائمة الخضرة في كيركلاند ،
واشنطن الآن في طليعة
العثور على علاج يشاركون فيه
في تجربة إكلينيكية لحالة REM de الشديدة ،
وهو دواء عن طريق الوريد يتم
إعطاؤه لمدة عشرة أيام بعد أن تم
إعطاؤه لأكثر المرضى 19 مرضًا.
.  يقول ريتو إنه أظهر
وعدًا حقيقيًا وكان ذلك مجرد المرحلة الأولى
من التجربة عندما تذهب إلى
المرحلة الثانية من التجربة ، فماذا يعني
ذلك ، لذا فإن المرحلة الثانية ستستخدم
هذا العمود الفقري بحيث يتلقى كل مريض
REM يختفي لأن
أظهرت التجربة الأولى من القانون الأول فائدة تقصر
مسار المرض وأظهرت إحصائيًا تقريبًا
انخفاضًا في معدل الوفيات في المرحلة الثانية ،
سيحصل بعض المرضى أيضًا على دواء مصاحب
يسمى ماريسا دينيب والذي يستخدم
لعلاج التهاب المفاصل الروماتويدي ولكن كل
مريض من Cova 19 في التجربة سيحصل  الآن يتم
علاجه باستخدام REM ليس شديدًا ، فلماذا هذه
الصفقة
الكبيرة الضخمة ، هذا هو أول
دواء مفيد مثبت علميًا
من حيث علاج Tsarskoe b2
تجارب الدواء تحدث عبر
68 موقعًا شارك أكثر من ألف
شخص في النتائج
تعافى المرضى بسرعة أكبر بنسبة 31٪ مع حركة العين السريعة إلى
شديدة مما يترجم إلى أربعة
أيام أقل من المعاناة في المستشفى
على الرغم من حدوث تحسن بنسبة 31٪  لا يبدو
وكأنه ضربة قاضية مائة بالمائة ، إنه
دليل مهم جدًا على المفهوم
لأنه ثبت أن دواءً ما يمكنه
منع هذا الفيروس يختفي REM وقد تم
إنشاؤه في الأصل كدواء
محتمل لعلاج إيبولا د.  كان ريتا أيضًا على
الخطوط الأمامية لتلك المعركة التي تسافر إلى
إفريقيا ، ويأمل أن يعمل الدواء هذه المرة ،
ولكن قبل إجراء هذه التجربة الثانية ،
أعلن الرئيس جنبًا إلى جنب مع الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة
Gilead الذي جعل العقار يعلن عن
تصريح الاستخدام الطارئ لـ REM des aveer من إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية.
العمل
على تحديد أفضل السبل لتوزيع ذلك
داخل الولايات المتحدة ، تتصرف إدارة الغذاء والدواء
بسرعة غير معتادة في الوقت
الحالي ، يتم استخدام الدواء فقط في المستشفيات
على مرضى كوفين 19 الأكثر مرضًا ، وهو
ليس علاجًا لبعض المرضى الذين
عولجوا بالعقار ما زالوا يموتون ولكن البعض الآخر  شعرت
بتحسن أسرع ، لذا يمكن أن تكون هذه
أداة رئيسية في مكافحة فيروس كورونا ،
فقط قم بتصحيح الضغط الذي يشعر به هؤلاء
العاملون الطبيون في الخطوط الأمامية ، لقد سمعنا القصة حتى
انفصل الكثير منهم عن
أحبائهم لفترات طويلة من الزمن.  لن
أعود إلى المنزل لساعات طويلة في محاولة للحصول
على معدات الحماية الشخصية التي
يحتاجون إليها ومن ثم التواجد حول الكثير من الموت
والمعاناة التي يجب أن ترتديها
نعم ، لا شك في أن جون أعني حتى
خارج الوباء بعد أن
تتحدث عن مجموعة ضعيفة من
الناس ، أعني أنك تعلم أن الموت عن طريق الانتحار
بين المجتمع الطبي أعلى
من عامة السكان وداخل
فرق الطوارئ الطبية وعاملي الطوارئ ،
أعلى حتى بين العاملين في المجال الطبي ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أن هناك الكثير من التوتر
وأعتقد أنه كان هناك الكثير من الأدوار غير المألوفة
وكذلك في كثير من الأحيان
صعبة مثل الأدوار التي يمكن أن تكون بالنسبة لفرق الطوارئ الطبية على
وجه الخصوص وأطباء الهواء لا
يزال هناك نمط  أشياء مثل
كيفية إنجاز الأشياء ، كيف تعمل نوعًا ما في
طريقك من خلال المشكلات عندما
تتعامل مع أشياء جديدة تمامًا
غير مألوفة والتي يمكن أن تكون صعبة حقًا ،
لقد سمعت أنه من الكثير من
زملائي أعتقد أن الافتقار إلى
الحماية الشخصية  المعدات أعني أنك
تعلم أننا تحدثنا كثيرًا عما تحدثنا عنه كثيرًا
وما زلنا نتحدث عنه
ضرائب نفسية كبيرة
لذلك ليس فقط لأنفسهم
من حيث  هل أنا بأمان هل
أصبت بالفيروس الذي تعرضت له للتو ، ولكن كما
ذكرت جون ، فمن المحتمل أن يعود إلى المنزل
ويعرضه للآخرين ،
وبعد ذلك فقط في الساعات التي أعني أنك تعرف
أن تسمعها د.  قصة برين والأب
يتحدثان عن ذلك ، أعني أنه كان
متعبًا للغاية بعد فترة
من حيث القدرة على التعامل مع هذه الأشياء ،
لذا من يدري أعني أنه دائمًا ما يكون
نوعًا شخصيًا من الأشياء وأنت تعلم أنه أمر
مأساوي ولكن  أعتقد أن هذه
بعض الأشياء التي تسمعها
من هؤلاء العاملين في الخطوط الأمامية ،
جون أنت تعلم أنك تكتب أن هذا الفيروس من
المحتمل أن يستمر في الانتشار لمدة ثمانية عشر
شهرًا إلى عامين والتوقعات
التي وضعتها كلاكما كانت حتى
ستين إلى سبعين عامًا  في المائة من
السكان في جميع أنحاء العالم لديهم هذا الأمر الذي أعلم أن
مارك قاله سابقًا في هذا البرنامج هو
نوع من كيفية تعريفه لمناعة القطيع ، لكنك
تحذر من أن هذا قد يشمل
موجة كبيرة ثانية من عدوى فيروس كورونا
في الخريف والشتاء ، لذا
السؤال لك يا جون  عندما تنظر إلى
هذه الأرقام ، يمكن أن تكون بهذه الطريقة
أكبر مما نراه الآن ،
فقد تكون تعلم أن ما رأيناه حتى
الآن قد تم التحكم فيه وتقليله
بشكل كبير بواسطة الفعل  الإجراءات التي اتخذناها
إذا تم الإفراج عن هذه الإجراءات وتوقف الأشخاص
عن الاهتمام
بالمسافة الاجتماعية التي تحتاج إليها حتى لو
أنهينا الإغلاق ، فلا يزال يتعين عليك مواصلة
التباعد الاجتماعي وتدابير الصحة العامة الأخرى ،
فقد يصبح
الأمر أسوأ بكثير
مما رأيناه.  تحذير شديد الواقعية إلى حد بعيد
أعني أنك تعلم أن
الفيروس ينتشر على الأقل لمدة
خمسة أشهر وما نفهمه حتى
الآن وفقًا للأرقام الرسمية ، أصيب أقل
من 1٪ من سكان العالم
بالعدوى الآن من الواضح أن هذا الرقم في
طريقه  أن تكون أعلى من ذلك بكثير ،
لكنها ستظل منخفضة جدًا مثل
نسبة سكان العالم ، لذا فإن
الوصول إلى 67 إلى 70 في المائة في غضون عامين
يعني فقط تسارعًا هائلاً
في مرحلة ما من علامة النمذجة الخاصة بك ،
نعم أعتقد ذلك جيدًا  بالطبع
لا يمكنك الانتقال من خمسة بالمائة في بضعة
أشهر إلى 70 بالمائة بدون
الكثير من الحالات التي كانت لدينا
حتى الآن ، وهذا يعني موجة أكبر
إذا واصلنا  تحت السيطرة من خلال
تدابير تحكم مكثفة حقًا ، قد لا
نصل إلى 50 أو 70 في المائة بحلول ذلك الوقت ، ولكن
بعد ذلك سنظل بحاجة
إلى لقاح أو مجموعة
لا تزال عرضة
لك